The Huffington Post published an article
in Twenty 15 titled No white people will
never understand the black experience,
the writer reasons that a white person,
no matter how blind to color,
can only understand so much if something
they cannot viscerally experience to
her.
Though white people must still educate
themselves on schematic racism to help
actively fight against something they
cannot truly understand in the movie
menace to society.
The Hughes brothers are on this exact
mission,
educating white people.
We've made that movie for white people.
We made the film to inform them of
something they didn't know.
In this video,
I want to explore how movies teach
prejudice using various engaging
cinematic techniques,
menace to society attempts to do what
the Huffington Post says is impossible.
The movie tries to give an outsider a
window into what it's like to grow up in
a poor black neighborhood,
and in doing so,
they teach outsiders to empathize with
people in that situation.
The movie accomplishes this from the
start in the first two moments,
the writing scene and the convenience
store robbery.
The writing footage purposefully gives a
distorted perspective of poor black
people from the opening shot.
The camera looks at the carnage of the
watts riots safely from a helicopter
like someone would see live news footage
on TV.
The camera is physically above the
violence and looking down on the people
riding.
Once we get to ride footage on the
ground to the filming is from the
perspective of the riot police.
Never the black people,
the white news commentator in the
background puts obvious emphasis on the
cops instead of the rioters
even the pixelation effect makes all the
black people look the same,
removing their face from the story.
This allows the viewer to easily
generalize them as a group,
not as individuals.
The Hughes brothers are cleverly
capturing the black experience in a
stereotypical way and in a way many
white people experienced black
communities from a distance and mostly
with stereotypes.
They further reinforced white
stereotypes of black people by showing
the main characters later,
robbing a convenience store at another
stereotypical black behavior.
They established this white bias so they
can spend the rest of the movie,
deconstructing it.
After the riot footage,
we go from a white commentator to a
black narrator and we no longer see the
black people from a distance.
We enter their homes and live within
their personal stories.
That was the first time I'd ever seen my
phone killing anybody,
but it wasn't the left I got used to it.
The to compliment this intimacy,
the violence in the film becomes much
grittier than the far removed violence
be normally see in news footage from a
helicopter.
The cinematography becomes clear,
colorful,
and up close.
This change was done intentionally by
the Hughes brothers to show that
violence is not like what we see on TV.
If it pops off,
make it pop off quick and make the
aftermath ugly.
Not like Rambo where guys just go down
and that's it.
Growing up,
most violence just looked goofy and
unorthodox.
People had twigs in their eyeballs and
shit.
It wasn't pretty by first using various
techniques,
establishing the black community as
faceless violent riders.
The rapid cinematic change of the black
community into up close,
relatable,
and vulnerable characters,
deconstructs the racial stereotypes.
Start with the poor black population as
an outsider sees them,
then bring the outsider in and challenge
their initial perspective with a
personal story of loss and excessive
violence.
Capture the racism and then deconstruct
it.
Getting white people on the inside of
poor black neighborhoods is a great
strategy to helping them understand the
cycle of poverty.
I remember when pitching the movie to
new line,
they go,
well,
what is different between this and when
we see the black guy on the news every
morning running from the helicopter,
I go,
well,
you're in the helicopter and you don't
know why that kid is running.
Actually,
films have used bias,
cinematic techniques to highlight sexism
as well as racism.
This has done more subtly but just as
powerfully in the silence of the lambs.
The main character arc in the movie is
clarice starling,
overcoming the mental trauma of her
childhood,
but there's also the backdrop of her
struggling to distinguish herself and in
almost all male professional men
sexualized clarice throughout the movie.
Whether it's subtly checking her out or
outright asking her on a date,
we see her isolation most powerfully and
subjective point of view shots
throughout the movie where we see
through the eyes of clarice all the
towering male figures looking down on
her.
These cinematic choices put us in the
perspective of the victim.
Even the final scene has immense staring
her down with her,
unable to see him echoing the men in her
career,
always watching her and looking down on
her.
The underlying idea here is that even
subjective experiences like growing up
in a poor black neighborhood or being a
woman in a male dominated profession
will always be impossible to experience
as an outsider,
but directors use subjective film making
techniques to try to recreate it,
and sometimes they do a pretty good job.
Of course they don't always get it
right.
It seems like historically mainstream
American cinema has had trouble
capturing authentic aspects of the Asian
experience.
Up until very recently,
Asian characters were almost always
either the Sensei who teaches using his
Americanized eastern wisdom for a racist
punchline.
Maybe the most important idea to grasp
in these discussions of creating film
bias is that they extend outside of
fictional storytelling.
In a famous example,
how is it possible that the police
officers who physically assaulted Rodney
King were acquitted?
There are many ways to approach this
question and the racial and political
reasons for their acquittal are
undeniable,
but another reason is necessary to
understanding that trial,
and it's how the lawyers defending the
Los Angeles police department distorted
the video footage of the beatings to
suit their story.
The defense attorneys broke the video
down into stills freezing the frame so
that the gesture,
the raised hand is torn from its
temporal place in the visual narrative.
The video is not only violence
decontextualized,
but violently recontextualized.
It has played without a simultaneous
soundtrack which had it existed,
would have been littered with racial and
sexual slurs against Rodney King,
but lawyers whitewashed the footage for
their own narrative.
This is a perfect example of racially
biased filmmaking used for evil.
The lawyers create a narrative that
white people are used to experiencing
and this deceit tries to justify the
obviously unjust beating of rodney king
using buys filmmaking to create a
distorted narrative is still happening.
By the way,
if you ever want to test this,
see how two different media outlets film
the same event.
If your network supports Betsy devoss,
her senate,
hearing his films like this,
if not,
it's films like this.
The HUFFINGTON post article may be
right,
quite people can never truly understand
the black experience,
and this also applies to men who never
truly understand what it's like to be a
woman in a male dominated field,
but the closest we can get maybe through
a close reading of commentary on the
black experience like in menace to
society or by the perspectives in camera
choices,
like in the silence of the lambs.
Each movie uses the power of
cinematography to show experiences
outside of our own race or gender,
and that's the beauty of movies.
We get sucked into lives and experiences
we could never possibly experienced
ourselves,
and some directors use that ability to
teach us something about the world
around us.
When these choices are used for good,
we learn about the human experience,
but when they're used for bad,
they cloud the truth and present the
world in a narrow minded and dangerous
way.
So keep a lookout.
Thanks for watching.